[Music]
do
hello everyone
welcome to the table we are so thrilled
that you're here and that you're able to
join us uh thank you for those of you
who are joining us and participating
online we are also very happy that
you're here to participate virtually so
thank you and for being here and welcome
uh i'll only have one announcement uh
this morning
evening
whenever you're watching this um so
great things about doing this virtually
so only one quick announcement so uh
this is a saved date for september 12th
we are going to be having um our
um
state of the table meeting uh that's a
very fancy way of maybe saying we're
having a family meeting uh we're just
getting together just talking about just
kind of where we are as a church uh
we're gonna talk about things that are
coming up in the fall um just the
direction where we're at talk about some
financial finances and just logistics
and then if that's a great way for you
to kind of we're going to talk about our
needs and if you want to kind of plug in
or just want to know where you can help
it's a great time to come and hear about
that so save the date for september
so
i'm going to launch us with a quick
prayer and then we'll get started
lord thank you so much for bringing us
all here together
thank you for uh where you have guided
us where you have led us this week
whether that's been places of greatness
where there's been places that have been
just very difficult no matter what that
this week has been for us
thank you that we can come here
that we can connect with you
know that you're walking with us knowing
that you're guiding us knowing that you
are there to
just give us strength
and a sense of community
christ
amen
thank you don
well we're so excited to spend some time
worshiping together so if you want to
stand on up
um
i am
excited to have these people with me on
stage and i just thought i'd really
quickly in case you don't know them this
is tyler this is caitlin and gary and my
name is mindy and one thing that i love
about worship is it doesn't matter if
you're on the stage or off the stage
your worship is the same there's
actually no extra points for
being in the band or being in the chairs
um
and i really my heart is for us to be
able to enter into a place together
where we're lifting up this creative
expression that's kind of claiming that
this is the god that we know and have
come to know and love through jesus um
so i just encourage you in these moments
think about the lyrics that worth
singing and try to connect with your
emotions and with your body as you use
your voice use your hands if you're
clapping or we might use our feet to
stomp because we are drummerless today
so uh you might see me and caitlyn
pounding out some beats here on graves
into gardens cause that bridge is a
killer without drum let me tell you so
you all join in okay and we just invite
you into the whole experience you're
welcome here you're wanted and um god is
with us so i hope that you can
experience him as we sing okay
gary's gonna get us started here
is
[Music]
your
goodness me
[Music]
oh
in us
[Music]
love will never fail
you're dead fast
the promises are true
you're faithful
[Music]
my eyes have seen your ways
your goodness
[Music]
righteousness
deep within
[Music]
deep within us
here we go
you see your goodness in the land of the
living
we see a goodness in the land of living
we see your goodness in the land of the
living
oh we see your goodness
[Music]
oh spirit
yes god thank you that you are here with
us
that you and your presence god
are very real and present to us and i
just pray that we can connect with that
tonight
[Music]
i searched the world
but it couldn't fill me
and then empty praise and treasures the
faith
are never enough
[Music]
and put me back together
and every desire
is now satisfied
[Music]
oh there's nothing
better
[Music]
nothing is better than you
and i'm not afraid
to show you my weakness
[Music]
the god of the mountains
and there's not a place his mercy and
grace won't find me again
oh
lord there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
know there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
better than you or there's nothing
nothing is better than you
you turn morning to dances
[Music]
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who cares
you turn graves into gardens
you turn bones into armies
you turn seas into highways
you're the only one who cares
[Music]
one who cares
all right let's lift it up just the
voices
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
hey
lord there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
sing that one more time
oh there's nothing
better
[Music]
morning
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who can
you turn graves into gardens
you turn bones into armies
[Music]
i'm gonna take us into our prayers of
the people and
i just invite you to lift up anything or
anyone who might be on your heart when
we get to that portion of the prayer
just join in and
if you're online feel free to enter your
prayers into the comments and karen will
be on our live feed and she'll read them
out for all of us to hear so that you
guys can also participate
we would love that so
i'll start us off
for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community
and all of those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
[Music]
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
[Music]
and god we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
ron and betty
yes
[Music]
for broken relationships
for students
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
caitlyn's gonna lead us in this next
song and it's just a very simple chorus
um and if you grew up with family that
was in church or maybe they took you to
church this might be something that
you've heard a million times and and one
verse in particular
um
i chose for us to sing tonight it says
he answers prayers and that's one that i
personally struggle with a lot because i
have a lot of prayers that i prayed that
were not answered and it was very
heartbreaking
um
and something that i really wrestled
with because it's not like it was a bad
prayer you know
it was good and i had all the right
people praying it with me and i had lots
of
you know prophetic words spoken about it
and then when things don't come to pass
it can be very
unsettling it can really um
at least for me it left me in a very raw
um kind of resentful place
but one thing that i try to remember and
hold on to any time i'm wrestling with
prayer
and just the nature of the beast
if you'll let me call it that
is that
his ways are beyond my ways
and although i don't believe that he's
the puppet master up in the sky pulling
strings and our heart strings being
included in that
i do know that i'm only seeing a
fraction of the whole picture
and what i can understand with my heart
and my mind here on this very broken and
hurting earth
is not the whole thing and i have to
believe that there is a grander bigger
story going on than just my story
and one thing that i've been praying out
in our prayers of the people
over these last several months just got
answered this last week
and
sometimes we get to celebrate when our
prayers get answered and sometimes they
don't get answered and we get to grieve
together in that
but i think that as a community one
thing that's beautiful there is that we
can still believe for god's very best in
every situation
even when it doesn't turn out the way
that we had hoped or the way that we had
prayed we can still support one another
we can stand together
and continue to pray and seek god and
hope that he will continue to show us a
bigger grander picture of his love
because i think that's what it boils
down to is that he is a loving and good
father
and we may not understand it all right
now but i hope that he'll continue to
show us that as we continue to seek him
together as a community
so
caitlin go ahead and
[Music]
god
is so
good
god is so
[Music]
is so
good
he's so
to me
he
answers prayers
answers
he answers
prayers
he's so
good
to
me
[Music]
is
one last time
[Music]
god is so
good
[Music]
god is so
good
he's so
to me
yes god we lift this service up to you
and our time together
thank you for community thank you for
people that can shoulder our burdens
with us
for people who love and care for one
another
would we be the tangible hands and feet
of jesus
in the lives of our family and our
friends
god
your love is real and your love is sweet
and i pray god that we experience more
of that as we share it with others
it's in your name i pray all these
things amen
you guys can be seated and go ahead and
turn to someone around you and say hello
and then brett will get us started with
the message
[Music]
nice
there goes the shaker
all right there we go
well good evening everyone
grace and peace it's really great to be
with you and uh and just a joy to to
welcome you here
and uh that includes
uh of course those joining us online we
love you a lot
and as well as those of you who are new
and kind of you know plugging in
um it can be you know somewhat
intimidating thing to
walk through the doors of a church
especially if it's been a while
and uh and depending on your past you
know in your own history um
there might be all sorts of feelings
that it just
kind of drums up and that can be really
challenging so um i'll just say i'm
really grateful that you're that you're
all here um
so i also wanted to mention before we
jump in that many of you know last week
we had a baptism really our first
baptism service here
at the table
and uh we kind of it was really kind of
more of a party it wasn't like a classic
service but um
i really i mean it was just it was
amazing like i knew it would be great i
knew it was going to be great but it
just surpassed all expectations i really
not only for the it's the individuals
who were baptized it seemed just deeply
meaningful and beautiful but really even
just for us as a whole church community
um it was like kind of a milestone it
was a holy moment it was um i think in
ways kind of god nudging us
um saying like hey
you're on the right track you know don't
grow weary in doing good i love that
phrase in the new testament don't grow
weary in doing good and um
and yeah it was just it was just a
wonderful wonderful time so i encourage
you if you maybe you missed it you can
go on to youtube
and look at the table tx
and find kind of our channel there and
you can just scroll we did the live feed
for a while but you can you know kind of
jump to the end and you'll see when we
actually start you know doing things and
what's really cool is each person who's
baptized had a chance to share a little
bit of their story whether it was you
know two sentences or a few minutes and
uh that it's amazing it's not something
you want to miss so i encourage you to
to go back uh and give that a listen so
um all right so we are in
uh part
four tonight in our series uh titled
deconstruction finding god again
uh in that term deconstruction it's kind
of a more modern popular term to refer
to kind of a season of questioning a
season of doubt a season of um some call
like a dark night of the soul kind of
that's that time when you're really
wrestling with your faith
and maybe even questioning
like can i stay with this can am i still
in the in the camp in the tribe of
christian i'm not so sure because i'm
just wrestling with certain um you know
doctrines or certain understandings
certain theologies of you know about god
and christ and myself and
you know scripture and all the things
and so what this series is doing is
trying to kind of tackle some of the
really big topics that people tend to
wrestle with and
i'm honestly i'm not trying to give
necessarily like new or novel um
interpretations of these things or like
some slant on it i'm what i'm tending to
do you'll find me saying this over and
over in the series is that i'm saying
things that seem new but it's really
just because they're so old
that they're new again
right it's it's things like because we
tend to especially in the west like we
kind of feel like you know anything
uh i don't know beyond like 50 years
like oh that's ancient you know and if
something's been around for a hundred
years oh well that's just eternity um
and of course the christian tradition is
2000 years old and so a lot of times we
haven't really engaged with someone like
you know gregory of nissa or origen
um even saint augustine like we you know
it's sort of like oh i don't know what
they said um and actually if you go back
there's some really life-giving really
amazing things so it's kind of we're
kind of on a treasure hunt in a way
we're kind of going back and looking
through the christian tradition to say
okay what's beautiful and life-giving
and helpful um
and so tonight of i think of any topic
this is probably one of the most kind of
contentious difficult
ones that people wrestle with so the
title is deconstruction and hell
uh yes
um
this was i know for me personally this
was a real sticking point when i was
about 12 years ago was my season of
deconstruction and doubt and wrestling
and um oh this was a really tough one
although interestingly enough there was
a number of um
books i read and that gave me this this
um
kind of a new a fresh understanding and
that in the in the end what happened
and we'll kind of get to a lot of this
tonight um you'll kind of see that um
it's not so much that i now like i don't
reject hell or just like oh i mean
because there's as we'll get into in
just a moment um this is like in the new
testament even the words of jesus he
talks about it um
but it was reading folks like c.s lewis
um
origen
um honzers von balthazar who's a
catholic theologian his book that all
shall be saved or shall shall all be
saved
just a number of people that all of a
sudden i realized how far from being
this sort of like the scariest worst
doctrine in the bible you know is
actually um quite stunning and
insightful and
um i mean dare i say it beautiful in
ways so uh
so we'll kind of get into that tonight
so this will be
buckle up because we are going to be uh
in the bible a lot like
at some level we always are i mean i'm
always preaching from the bible but you
know some nights are kind of preaching
nights that's where you're like
announced jesus is lord and kind of get
everyone fired up and then there's like
teaching nights and that's the where
you're like in the chat and this is a
teaching night you know this isn't like
rah-rah you're going to feel all the
happy you know or like excited it's not
it's just not that kind of message it is
like a deep dive get into it which for
some of you you're like yes finally
uh and others you're like oh no um
but i think if you'll hang with me
there's a payoff at the end and i think
where we get is really um is really
helpful so uh with that in mind we'll
start um by reading we're gonna have
three passages tonight that lets you
know right away like oh very serious um
so matthew 25 we'll start here um verses
through 46 actually referenced this text
i think it was two weeks ago
this is the famous parable of the sheep
and the goats where jesus has this kind
of judgment day scene and the sort of
the the people who were faithful and
loved well were the sheep and then the
goats are the other folks so he says
this verse 37 then the righteous that'd
be the sheep we'll answer him
lord when did we see you hungry and feed
you or thirsty and give you something to
drink
when did we see you a stranger and
invite you in or needing clothes and
clothe you when did we see you sick or
in prison and go to visit you
verse 40 the king will reply truly i
tell you whatever you did for one of the
least of these brothers and sisters of
mine you did for me
and then he will say to those on his
left this would be the goats
depart from me
you who are cursed into the eternal fire
prepared for the devil and his angels
for i was hungry and you gave me nothing
to eat i was thirsty and you gave me
nothing to drink i was a stranger you
did not invite me in i needed clothes
and you did not clothe me i was sick and
in prison and you did not look after me
and they also will answer
lord
when
when did we see you hungry or thirsty or
stranger or needing clothes or sick or
in prison and did not help you and he
will reply truly i tell you whatever you
did not do for one of the least of these
you did not do for me and then they will
go away to eternal punishment but the
righteous to eternal life
all right our next passage is luke
chapter 13
verses 22 through 30.
then jesus went through the towns and
villages teaching as he made his way to
jerusalem and someone asked him lord are
only a few people
going to be saved
he said to them make every effort to
enter through the narrow door
because many i tell you will try to
enter and will not be able to
once the owner of the house gets up and
closes the door you will stand outside
knocking and pleading sir open the door
for us but he will answer i don't know
you or where you come from then you will
say well we ate and drank with you and
you you taught in our streets but he
will reply i don't know you or where you
come from away from me all you evil
doers
and there will be
weeping there and gnashing of teeth when
you see abraham and isaac and jacob and
all the prophets in the kingdom of god
but you yourselves thrown out and people
will come
from east and west and north and south
and will take their places in the feast
in the kingdom of god indeed there are
those who are last
who will be first
and first
who will be last this by the way is the
teaching of the great reversal um that
happens at the end of all things that in
other words what jesus is saying is um
there are those who in this life
they were like first place winners they
had it all they had the money and the
success and the you know whatever kind
of worldly standards of success that we
have they won big but he's saying those
folks many of them are going to find
that actually at the end of all things
they're like in last place and those who
in this life
were like nobodies
and then all of a sudden
they're ushered to the front of the line
it's a beaut i think it's a challenging
but a powerful picture and actually keep
that image in mind towards the very end
of the message as well all right our
final passage is going to be mark
chapter 9 verses 42 through 49 and i'm
reading all these by the way to give you
kind of a snapshot like a big picture
all the places where jesus talks about
some sort of you know post-mortem after
death kind of judgment or something all
right mark 9.
jesus says if anyone causes one of these
little ones
who believe in me those who believe in
me to stumble it would be better for
them if a large millstone were hung
around their neck and they were thrown
into the sea
he's uh he's not mincing words here uh
verse 43 if your hand causes you to
stumble cut it off it's better for you
to enter life maimed than with two hands
to go into hell where the fire never
goes out and if your foot causes you to
stumble cut it off it is better for you
to enter life crippled than to have two
feet and be thrown into hell
and if your eye it causes you to stumble
pluck it out it is better for you to
enter the kingdom of god with one eye
than to have two eyes and be thrown into
hell where and now he's quoting the book
of isaiah
where the worm that eats them that eat
them do not die and the fire is not
quenched verse 49 then everyone will be
salted with
fire
okay
so you might be thinking like well seems
pretty clear to me
my hellfire and brimstone preacher had
it right
um and so what i want to do is i want to
give you three observations
and uh
these some of them might be a little bit
counter-intuitive although i don't
once you know what to look for i think
they're fairly obvious i don't think i'm
like stretching the text or something
so let me give you three observations
that will bring some clarity
to these so observation number one
tonight
is notice it's a judgment by works
uh i.e of our of our living
which is is really interesting so um for
example in matthew 25
uh it's
it's pretty clear we'll read just a
section again then you will say to those
on his left depart from me you are
cursed into the eternal fire prepared
for the devil and his angels and then
what's the basis of this
for i was hungry and you gave me nothing
to eat i was thirsty you gave me nothing
to drink i was a stranger you did not
invite me in i needed clothes you did
not clothe me i was sick i was in prison
you did not look after me et cetera et
cetera like can you kind of get how this
is like a very tangible it's i mean he
doesn't say like well you always skipped
out on sunday school
right that's not his his answer or you
didn't go to church enough it's it's
like these very practical
feeding hungry people taking care of the
sick i mean it's like living right
um or in luke 13 it's similar he says
but he will reply i don't know you or
where you come from away from me all you
evildoers
in other words doers of evil things
right can you see how this is about this
is about our living or mark chapter 9
verse 43 if your hand
causes you to stumble if your foot
causes you to stumble if your eye causes
you to stumble
now that last passage i should mention
it's pretty clear jesus is speaking in
hyperbole there meaning exaggeration to
make a point
as far as we know there is no evidence
that any of jesus disciples you know
sinned and then immediately chopped off
their hand like oh i'm wicked you know
like this was not a thing so
um so just to be clear
don't take these this overly literally
um he's he's
he's really he's preaching to large
crowds and so i think he's he's using
rhetoric to you know sway people like
he's well in essence what is he getting
at i think he's getting at the same
thing that matthew 25 is getting at um
the thing luke 13 the doers of evil i
mean he's basically saying look
how you live
matters
how we live
it's kind of a big deal why because
um
we have the power in our living
to bring
either heaven or hell to earth
and i think in essence what jesus is
kind of getting at is um
don't be surprised if your whole life
has just been characterized by bringing
hell to earth
well then at the end of all things don't
be surprised by some sort of
judgment or something along those lines
um
i i should say uh
that with this idea of of how we live
this is both i think a little bit
challenging for us on the one hand it
kind of might unsettle us at least as
like you know christian folks here in a
church like oh my gosh well what are you
saying you know it can make us uneasy on
the other hand um
i think it does sort of open up things
in a way
because i do think there's kind of a
paradox in the new testament where we
are saved by the grace and goodness of
god i really i trust that when jesus
says like i'm the way the truth and the
life no one comes to the father except
through me um
i believe that i'm a christian so i
think that's true um but we often frame
that almost as though jesus is standing
in the way
instead of being the way instead of
opening up the way for all people we
almost think of it as
uh uh i'm the way don't you oh you
thought you were gonna get in no uh
right and it's and we started playing
this game of like the christian
non-christian
um
even we can often get i've heard
christians get quite judgmental about
people who aren't in you know in the
christian camp
and and almost delight a little bit in
someone who is um
say you know not a christian like
they're part of a different religious
tradition and but they're like a good
person you know like pretty their life
of course only god knows the heart but
their life is pretty clearly
characterized by like humility and
kindness and they you know will
volunteer and they're taking care of the
poor and they're loving their friends
and family and even their enemies well i
mean they're just like pretty darn good
people and i've heard christians almost
delight
in in kind of mocking and sort of
implying basically like well
you know they're still gonna burn
you know i've heard christians say
things like this and this is what's so
interesting is can you see how um almost
opposite that is of these passages
can you see that i mean it's
it's it's amazing how easily we can
ignore the bible
and um
and so this is i think this is what
jesus is there's there's a certain
judgment um
by works of of our um of our living
um okay so that's the first kind of
counterintuitive
uh insight here
second observation is i want you to
notice that the language is highly
metaphorical
and somewhat vague by vague i mean
there's no like super detailed doctrine
of hell being spelled out here because
often when we start hearing about hell
our minds immediately jump to dante's
inferno
um
with this kind of elaborate like oh yeah
i know that the place where you know
satan's there with a pitchfork and the
demons have the hot pokers and like
depending on your sins then you're like
go to the worst places in hell you know
it's like this very elaborate kind of
like oh yeah i know what i know what
this verse is talking about and i think
we start jump sort of jumping and maybe
you could say reading a lot into the
text that isn't actually there um which
i will i'll start to unpack um so
whether it's you know matthew 25 using
this language of the sheep and the goats
in this judgment day type scene and a
king
um
i mean clearly jesus is he's trying to
describe something real this sort of end
of all things judgment day type scene
but he's using metaphor
to do it um or similar with the luke 13
with the whole language of knocking at
the door like are you saying that
heaven's like a door and and then we're
there and we have to like knock to enter
it's like well okay it's again it's sort
of this picture of a house but he's he's
speaking in metaphor um now the last
passage the mark 9
probably of any of them it might seem
like the most straightforward and but
actually as we press into it i think
you'll see it's the most metaphorical
now what do i mean by it seems like it's
the most straightforward um
well basically it i mean it's the one
that says hell over and over and over
so you know it just seems pretty
straightforward uh so just to kind of
remind you verse uh here's verse 43 it
is better for you to enter life maimed
than with two hands to go into hell
where the fire never goes out
verse 45 be thrown into hell verse 47 be
thrown into hell verse 48 where the
worms that eat them do not die and the
fire is not quenched um so again that
seems like i don't know any metaphor
going on there um so here's what's
interesting uh the the word that's
translated into english
as hell here it is the greek word um
gehenna
and gehenna
which is basically a transliteration
into greek out of hebrew so in hebrew
it's it's literally the valley of hanom
this is what jesus is saying the valley
of hanom or he's saying
gehenna
and
what's interesting is that this was an
actual place
in
the ancient world
um this was basically it was so you had
jerusalem which kind of had a wall
around it for like defense so it was
this valley next to um the city of
jerusalem
and uh in ancient times
the the children of israel when they um
when they weren't following god and they
were engaged in idolatry
this is where they worship the god
molech and they engage child sacrifice
there
and so what what happened is over time
it became there was a stigma there was a
taboo around the valley of hanom gehenna
it was like the place you know just real
estate was cheap you know we'll put it
that way like no one wants to you don't
move to the valley of hinom no one's
hanging out there it's sort of that
place you know that's kind of like oh do
we have maybe we'll go around the valley
of hanoi you know like let's on our
journey we don't don't go through you
don't want to go there
um
and and we we know actually later
there's a rabbi um a jewish rabbi who in
the year this is the year um 1200 a.d
this is a good thousand years after
jesus is giving this teaching which is
why some scholars sort of speculate like
oh how accurate is this we aren't sure
but this rabbi said that back in like
the first century
that eventually the valley of hanom
became the
dump
for jerusalem which doesn't make a
certain logical sense if no one wants to
live there
no you know it's like what are we going
to do with this place well we could put
our trash there
and and so this is apparently what they
did and this rabbi and
this is a thousand years ago he actually
says
that in the valley of hanom in gehenna
the fires
never go out
that's what he says
and why because it was they were burning
trash there
this is sort of how they dealt with
their you know refuse and such in the in
the ancient world
and so
again this is where we have to be really
careful when we read these kinds of
passages because we
when jesus is preaching he says gehenna
like he's saying like look if
if you live in such a way that you're
bringing hell to earth
if you're you're not looking after the
poor if you're just living a life of
egoism and selfishness and greed like
be careful
because you just might end up at the end
of all things
in the dump
in um in gehenna
like children you should stay in that
room this is a very intense message you
know
um
which is so different right than
you'll end up in dante's inferno in the
12th circle of hell can you see how what
appears on its surface to be like the
most literal like oh hell um i know what
that is all of a sudden
gehenna again it's this sort of metaphor
and i'm not by the way saying it so it's
nothing at all or like clearly he's
using it as a metaphor as an image of a
not good place
but can you see how that's slightly
different than
you'll end up in the place where god
will torture you for all eternity and
right we have this like elaborate thing
worked out where he's all of his first
century heroes are they're hearing
something different
they're hearing
like i mean the same way if you've ever
been to the city of saxi dump
um it is it's sort of hellish
um you know it's sort of this place like
i don't want to be there a long time
um and i mean imagine if that's what he
was saying like you don't want your life
to end up on the dump heap
like
live faithfully love well that's a i
mean can you see oh this is
this is slightly different than than
often um
i think what we imagine so now i can um
if i were you probably what i'd be
asking though is like well what about
that matthew 25 passage specifically
verse 46 because didn't it say something
about eternal punishment like that seems
very dante's inferno
and that's a good point so let's jump
into that um
this is just to be clear it's verse 46
then they will go away to eternal
punishment but the righteous to eternal
life matthew 25 46. so this leads me to
my third
observation which is that translation um
is interpretation
what do i mean well you might think that
um translating you know words from greek
into english is just as simple as like
well you have a greek word and you find
its exact equivalent in english and
wemo there you go no prob um but of
course if you know anything about
translating and specifically translating
like ancient languages
this is much easier said than done
because words right change meaning over
time it gets uh it can be quite complex
and this is why
if you look at various translations they
often can vary quite a bit around
specifically this passage matthew 25 46.
um
what i want to do i'm going to give you
two groups of translations tonight of
that specific verse
um three verses in each group the first
group we'll call these the eternal
punishment slash torture translations
and then we'll have the um i kind of how
did i phrase these sort of the
the temporary punishment um slash
purification kind of group so let's
start with the the super intense ones so
the first is the niv which we've kind of
already read um
or not kind of we literally already read
it uh it says then they will go away to
eternal punishment but the righteous to
eternal life or here's the king james
and these shall go away into everlasting
punishment but the righteous into life
eternal or here's the aramaic bible in
plain english this was the most intense
translation i could find
it says and these will go into eternal
torture
and the righteous into eternal life okay
so that's that group let's look at this
is a second group
this is the uh
the temporary punishment slash
purification group i'm going to start
with the weymouth new testament and
these shall go away into the punishment
of the ages
can you see how we're already a little
bit different like
okay
punishment of the ages but the righteous
into the life of the ages uh here's the
world new testament and these shall go
away into age-lasting punishment but the
righteous into age-lasting life
or the new testament a translation this
is by david bentley heart and these will
go to the chastening of that age but the
just to the life of that age
so this of course begs the question why
why these differences what's
what's going on here um because i think
you'll probably agree that first group
like that really that packs quite a
punch especially that um
the aramaic translation in particular
that really
you know
that's yeah these pack a punch but
saying
you know if you if you live in such a
way that you bring hell to earth and you
you live in just egoism and greed and um
aren't generous like well then at the
end of all things um you will be
for chastened
season
can you hear that's a little bit
different than you will be tortured
forever
forever some of you got that joke if
you're
sand sandlot yeah um
so
okay so this the reason for the
difference is it comes down to two um
two greek words the first is um colossis
colossis um which means pruning or
confinement or punishment or
chastisement this is why most the
translations opted for punishment
the aramaic bible in plain english they
went a little intense they went for the
torture i honestly i read probably 100
translations this week i did not find
one other one that opted for the word
torture um
and i think there's good reason for this
there's actually a different word in
greek that would be more along the lines
of torture it's the word um the greek
word temoria it means
torture retributive punishment
payback
but it's interesting that that's not the
word that jesus used
instead he uses colosseus
not tomorrow which is fascinating
because we tend to equate when we think
hell we're like oh yeah mm-hmm so even
as i read the passage at the beginning
you're probably hearing these like oh we
know what that is but what you're
thinking is tomorrow what you're
thinking is torture
payback time you live terrible and now
i'm gonna get you you know it's my
chance now you had your 80 years to get
it right but i have the rest of eternity
like this is this can you hear how our
image of god there is like fully jacked
up um
so it's not tomorrow he actually he uses
the language of um of colosseus
which is it's this idea of of
discipline or punishment that
leads i think to a good place right if
you think of even a good parent and a
bad parent a bad parent does temoria
right vengeance payback you embarrass me
now i'm gonna right and it's sort of an
abusive
thing we crossed the line into tomorrow
and it is not good
um colossis is i think good parenting
like a good parent isn't just like oh
well whatevs
you know no bags it doesn't matter how
you treat people that's not good
parenting but it's you discipline with
the intent to instruct to move forward
to to um
to heal to mature all right so that's
the idea of colossus um
and that's the word for punishment so
what about this whole age thing or
eternal versus not and all that so this
comes back to the word um the greek word
ionios
ionios this has
different meanings um it can mean
endless duration which is why some of
the translations go with eternal or
forever or everlasting
but it can also mean just a long period
of time
or it can even just mean a substantial
interval
yes
how long
i don't know you know at least a week
probably um
but can you hear like how they're sort
of playing that which is why this i
label this observation translation is
interpretation because can you see how
you bring like the translator when they
come to a greek word like this and you
say what does ionios mean well it can
mean three different things
and so can you see how you as a
translator you bring your theology you
bring
your image of god you bring all of your
presuppositions to the text and then
based on
that and based on certain things you see
in the verse and chapter like you then
make a decision about okay i think i
know what this is talking about and then
you go which is why we have these two
groups of translations that are so
different like i mentioned earlier you
know chastening for a season is like
completely different than eternal
torture um and yet but am i saying like
um
that a certain group is wrong based on
just the greek words no like you could
go either way based on what's there so
what's interesting is often um
uh folks will
uh
i think they'll kind of push back on
someone who's who thinks of hell as not
god torturing people forever as though
they're going kind of you know soft on
scripture or something like that um
when
i think the point is both of these are
very viable options for a translator
coming
to the text so they just they have to
make a decision
um
and which is why the majority go with
group number one most and why because
that's sort of the dominant
interpretation in the tradition that's
where most people have tended to go
especially in the last 500 to 1000 years
before that
actually group number two was arguably a
bit more popular in terms of the way a
lot of the church fathers
understood this
so um
okay so what am i kind of getting at um
with all of this well
you can probably tell just if you've
heard any of my sermons or been at the
table for any length of time um which
group of translations i tend towards
and um
it's
in the the reason well obviously it's
sort of group number two um and i think
i think i said this maybe a few weeks
ago but any time our image of god it
starts to sound like the devil
i think that's like real problematic
and so this is one reason i don't opt
for translation group number one um
and this this message it couldn't it
could just be too long so i can't get
into all the reasons for that but i just
think oh that would be my shorthand
version it's just like hey it just
starts to sound too much like the devil
to me i can't can't go with eternal
torture forever i just can't go that
road
and so
how do i understand hell the way i've um
kind of summed it up is when i think of
hell i think of it as the furious love
of god
that is burning away that is purifying
us of everything that holds us back from
him
i think that's the heart i think that's
actually what's going um on
here in texts like this
which means in other words that hell
it's not about it's not the evil you
know father or the abusive parent
getting back it's not tamoria
but it's colossus it's it's discipline
it's instruction it's um ultimately it's
not hatred it's healing it's not
retributive justice it's restorative
justice
um
there's uh i'll close with this there's
a beautiful
uh short story and actually the last
time i preached john hell was maybe
eight or nine months ago we were online
and i don't know how many of you ever
heard that message i think there was
maybe five people still logging on at
that time everyone was really sick of
online church so um so i'm going to
reuse
my ending there for that message because
i there's this short story that i think
is just the perfect picture of what hell
is all about so it's from uh flannery
o'connor
and if you know her she was a
writer she was a catholic christian
and um
she tells the story
of
the title is revelation
and there's a woman who's named miss
turpin
and she is this basically pharisaical
judgmental she's a christian but she's
like real bad and basically the the
setting is that she's sitting in this
doctor's office in this short story
and
there's all these people in the room
with her and she's like judging every
single one of them she's there's people
of different races people different body
types different class levels just
o'connor intentionally places all
different sorts of people in the room
and you're in miss turpin's mind and
hearing her commentary and she is just
slamming them all i mean it's awful she
is
racist and classist i mean just all the
things she's just a bad person
um but she feels but she's so smug and
self-righteous because she's saved
right
so
so it's her and her husband claude
oh that's great i like that name claude
so they're sitting there when suddenly
ms turpin has her moment of revelation
when a woman named grace
which i think o'connor is choosing that
name very intentionally grace
throws a book at ms turpin's face and
calls her an old warthog
and this just jars miss turpin i mean
she's just shocked and offended because
she says like i'm a good person i'm not
an old warthog
and
suddenly
she has this moment this vision which is
is the part i want to read
it says a visionary light
settled in her eyes
and miss turpin she saw the streak as a
vast swinging bridge extending upward
from the earth through a field of living
fire
can you see the imagery here
through a field of living fire and upon
it a vast horde of souls were tumbling
toward heaven and there were whole
companies of white trash clean for the
first time in their lives in battalions
of freaks and lunatics shouting and
clapping and leaping like frogs
and bringing up the end of the
procession
was a tribe of people
remember the end
the first shall be yes
the end of the procession was a tribe of
people whom she recognized at once as
those who like herself and claude had
always had a little of everything and
the god-given wit to use it right
and she leaned forward to observe them
closer they were marching behind the
others with great dignity accountable as
they had always been for good order and
common sense and respectable behavior
they alone were singing on key
and yet she could see
by their shocked and altered faces
that even their virtues
were being burned
away
i love this image
this is a pic
what o'connor's giving you is this
picture of hell but not not hell as
eternal torment and i'm going to get you
back forever
but as a as the purifying fires of god's
love
i love particularly that ending with
even their virtues
i think
we can of course virtue means you know
good things i don't think o'connor means
literally you know their love their
faith their hope their peace was being
burned away i think remember
ms turpin is this pharisaical religious
person
who's all about looking good who's all
about virtue and doing it right and
and so i think this is such a powerful
image of basically naming even the good
things even all the rule following and
obeying and that was still driven by ego
and self-righteousness that even that by
the goodness and grace of god is being
burned away
i think this is
powerful
powerful and this is why i actually
think
what if hell is good
news like what if it's not the moment
where we see like the dark side of god
but what if it's
it is still i mean if god is love then
even hell
is an expression of the love of god not
getting us back
but purifying us healing us of
everything that holds us back from him
all right let me pray lord jesus
i thank you
i thank you for the revelation of your
love
and i lift up
every brother and sister here tonight
who
um
might have really lived their lives even
in fear of hell or confused about hell
and just not sure what to do with this
this teaching
and
god i pray that
god all of us we would come
to understand that you are the god of
love
and there is no
um
there is no darkness in you there is no
fear in you there is no hatred and venom
no temoria in you
god
but you love us with an everlasting love
and so i pray that here at the table god
we would be
a people
set free from um fear
fear of torture fear
of payback and retribution
and instead we would be a people set on
fire by your love
called to live beautiful lives
called to live in grace
called to love well
that's our heart god
it's in the powerful and life-changing
name of jesus that i pray
amen
[Music]
will your grace
if i
let you
down
[Music]
is
cause i am a sinner if it's not one
thing it's another
i'm caught up in words
[Music]
but you are a savior and you take
brokenness aside and they keep
[Music]
if i
tell you
[Music]
is how to
cry
[Music]
i am a sinner if it's not a one thing
it's
another i'm caught up in words tickled
in lies
but you are a savior and you take
brokenness aside and make it good
[Music]
beautiful
you make it beautiful
oh you make it beautiful
if it's not a one thing
[Music]
you take brokenness aside and make it
beautiful
[Music]
i am a sinner it's not a one thing
brokenness aside
[Music]
god you make us beautiful
beautiful
[Music]
let's pray
lord thank you so much
just for this evening
thank you for
just helping us know
that you have a plan for us
that you
have a purpose for each one of us no
matter where we are
no matter where we've been
um and that future is secure
i pray that you just be with us this
week uh just help us to kind of remember
all these things as we go out
and just hopefully that we can
share this with others christ and i pray
amen
so
we always hope that every single time
that we have a service that this brings
you closer to jesus and if there's
anything
that
what that hits you in this message or
hits you throughout worship
you just need prayer
i'm here to pray with you
i would love to do that
also if you uh are a visitor we have
some cards in the off the table it's
just we just want to see you just have
welcome so they're gonna fill that out
um and just
there's a box outside you can place that
there and then also if you'd like to
give there's also an envelope
and a box also outside on the table you
can do that as well and
do that online
for us
because brett did such a great job just
going through scripture
it was very scripture intense uh this
evening i actually pulled our
addiction specifically out of uh
scripture as well so this is very sweet
and very short
but
made the grace of the lord jesus christ
and the love of god and the fellowship
of the holy spirit
have a great week
[Music]
oh you make it beautiful
you make it beautiful
[Music]
last time
oh
you make it beautiful
[Music]
foreign